vor 15 Jahren starteten elf Länder ein
gigantisches Gio engineering-projekt die
great greenwall von Afrika ein Wald 15
km breit und 8000 km lang einmal quer
über den Kontinent entlang der Sahara
das klingt super krass aber trotzdem
hört man von dem Projekt ja kaum etwas
das liegt daran dass es bisher auch
nicht weit gekommen ist es gibt nämlich
eine ganze Reihe von Schwierigkeiten
wenn man einen riesigen Wald mitten in
die Wüste pflanzen will wer hätte das
gedacht aber seit kurzem nimmt das
Projekt wieder Fahrt auf wie rettet man
also ein Riesenprojekt nun anscheinend
indem man ist noch größer und noch
ambitionierter macht und wie das
aussieht das zeige ich euch jetzt
acht Monate am Stück ohne Regen sind
nicht ungewöhnlich im Sahel der Zone die
die größte Wüste der Welt nach Süden
begrenzt Ende der 60er Jahre setzte dann
auch noch eine jahrzehntelange
Trockenzeit ein die Hungersnot in
Äthiopien Mitte der 80er Jahre war
besonders hart seitdem normalisieren
sich die Regenfälle wieder und die Natur
erholt sich langsam aber die Ecke und
Weiden erholen sich dummerweise nicht
der Boden bleibt unfruchtbar und 135
Millionen Menschen sind ständig von
Hungersnöten bedroht 2017 erst sind
einige Länder des Sahel von einer
hungersnotheim gesucht worden der Grund
für die unfruchtbaren Ecker sind die
fehlenden Bäume denn während bei
traditionellen Anbaumethoden die Bäume
auf Eckern stehen gelassen werden sie
seit der Kolonialzeit beim Anlegen
gefällt ohne Schatten und Windschutz
trocknen die Böden aus und werden
mitsamt der Nährstoffe weggewählt
ohne Bäume man geht es auch an Feuerholz
das besorgen sich die Menschen dann von
den Bäumen die zum Beispiel auf den
Weideflächen stehen an vielen Stellen
gibt es deshalb einfach gar keine Bäume
mehr und man verbrennt stattdessen den
dummen der Weidetiere den man dann auch
nicht mehr zum Düngen benutzen kann der
verhärtete und unfruchtbar gewordene
Boden nimmt dann auch nicht mehr den
wenigen Regen auf und weil Vögel und
Insekten kein Lebensraum mehr haben
breiten sich Krankheiten und Schädlinge
unter den Feldfrüchten aus vor allem da
wo der Sahel direkt an diese Haare
grenzt werden ganze Landstriche von der
Wüste verschluckt wegen des schlechten
Bodens produzieren die Ecker und Weiden
natürlich immer weniger Nahrung pro
Fläche deshalb sind die Menschen
gezwungen immer mehr Flächen für die
Landwirtschaft zu nutzen und das heißt
noch mehr Bäume fällen ihr seht das ist
ein Teufelskreis und oben drauf kommt
dann auch noch der steigende Bedarf an
Nahrung für die weiter wachsende
Bevölkerung man erwartet dass bis 2050
über 300 Millionen Menschen im Sahel
leben werden die Situation der ohnehin
schon Armen Bevölkerung verschlechtert
sich also laufend der Ausblick mehr
Hunger mehr Konflikte und mehr
Auswanderung teilweise auch nach Europa
die Lage in Afrika betrifft also auch
uns das alles ist ziemlich scheiße ich
glaube man kann es nicht anders sagen
also was kann man dagegen tun
wenn Bäume fehlen dann pflanzt man
einfach neue logisch oder
2007 gründete die Afrikanische Union
deshalb eine Agentur für die Errichtung
einer grünen Wand gegen die Sahara durch
die elf Länder der Sahelzone ein 50 km
breiter Waldstreifen von Dakar bis
jibuti sollte diese Sahara aufhalten
finanziell Unterstützung kam von der
Weltbank der EU und den Vereinten
Nationen aber ziemlich bald hat man
gemerkt so einfach geht das nicht von
den gepflanzten Bäumen haben nämlich
vier Fünftel nicht überlebt und die
wenigen Erfolge sind ungleichmäßig
verteilt insgesamt wurden nur 18% der
gesteckten Ziele erreicht
4%, wenn wir nur die great greenwall an
sich rechnen was das heißt dazu kommen
wir gleich lass uns vorher noch mal kurz
über den Partner in dieser Folge
sprechen nämlich immer den kennt ihr
vielleicht schon wenn ihr unsere Doku zu
erneuerbaren Energien gesehen habt
Tipper ist ein flexibler Stromanbieter
bei dem ihr Strom quasi in Echtzeit vom
Markt beziehen könnt damit habt ihr die
Möglichkeit den Strom dann zu Verb
brauchen wenn er gerade besonders
günstig ist und ihr seid flexibler als
mit gängigen Fixpreis Verträgen wenn ihr
zum Beispiel im Homeoffice arbeitet
könnt ihr eure Waschmaschine einfach
dann anschmeißen wenn es sich preislich
gerade lohnt und wann das der Fall ist
könnt ihr einfach in der Tipper App
sehen zusätzlich ist Strom auch immer
dann besonders nachhaltig wenn er
günstig ist weil er dann zu großen
Teilen aus erneuerbaren Energien kommt
ziemlich praktisch zu diesem dynamischen
Tarif kommen dann natürlich noch die
üblichen Steuern Abgaben sowie eine
Servicegebühr in Höhe von 3,99 € drauf
aber tatsächlich keine Gewinnmarge für
Zimmer selber damit ihr Zimmer zum
stündlich aktuellen Börsenstrompreis
nutzen könnt müsst ihr euren Stromzähler
erstmal etwas Nachhilfe geben und dafür
gibt's den stromtrackers den den ganz
einfach auf euren digitalen Zähler
aufsetzen könnt der Pauls sendet eure
Verbrauchsdaten in Echtzeit an die App
und so sieht ihr immer wie viel ihr
gerade verbraucht und dadurch verdient
übrigens Tipper sein Geld nicht mit dem
Strom den sie euch verkaufen sondern mit
den Gadgets
wenn ihr beim Anmelden den Code Watson
eingibt dann bekommt ihr nach
Vertragsabschluss einen 50 Euro
Gutschein für den Shop damit unterstützt
sie auch uns und unsere Videos der
Wechsel dort nur 5 Minuten und in der
App findet ihr alle Infos zum effektiven
Stromsparen und falls euch das noch
nicht gefällt dann könnt ihr innerhalb
von zwei Wochen einfach wieder kündigen
und jetzt geht's zurück zum Video wo
waren wir stehen geblieben ach so
einfach so einen Wald in die Wüste zu
pflanzen das funktioniert so nicht aber
was genau ist schief gegangen nun so
einiges man hat z.B schnell wachsende
Baumarten gepflanzt die aber nicht in
der Sahel Region heimisch sind
Eukalyptus z.B diese Arten sind oft
eingegangen manchmal wurden sie aber
auch zur invasiven Spezies die jetzt die
heimischen Pflanzen bedroht und an
vielen Orten gab es einfach niemanden
der sich um die neu gepflanzen Setzlinge
kümmern konnte oder die Menschen wurden
nicht in das Projekt eingebunden
stattdessen wurden sie mit Zäunen aus
bepflanzen Zonen ferngehalten solche
Pflanzungen wurden dann häufig für
Feuerholz vandalisiert was natürlich
nicht gerade zielführend ist der Plan
funktionierte aber da wo die Bewohner
eingebunden wurden statt Wälder zu
pflanzen zeigte man den Bauern wie man
wie in der präkolonialen Landwirtschaft
die heimischen Bäume pflegt um
nachhaltig Feuerholz zu bekommen und wie
man die Qualität der Böden erhöht oder
man gab den Einwohnern Setzlinge von
Obstbäumen von denen sie noch heute
essen können Viehzüchter erhalten Futter
aus Früchten heimischer Bäume für ihre
Ziegen wenn die Tiere die Samen auf der
Weide ausscheiden können dort neue Bäume
wachsen die dann wieder Futter für die
Tiere bereitstellen wow es ist fast so
als müsste man die Natur einfach mal
machen lassen so hat sich das great
green wall-projekt über die Jahre auf
jeden Fall angepasst und die
Erfolgschancen sind heute wahrscheinlich
größer als jemals zuvor allerdings hatte
sich so gewandelt dass man eigentlich
nicht mehr von einer great green Wall
sprechen kann denn statt einfach Bäume
auf einem Band von 120.000
Quadratkilometer zu pflanzen geht es nun
darum 100 Millionen Quadratkilometer
Fläche mit regional angepassten Methoden
wieder sichtbar zu machen und die liegen
auch nicht mehr nur in der Sahelzone
sondern auch im neuen weiteren
afrikanischen Ländern
232 Millionen Menschen leben in dem
vergrößerten Aktionsgebiet und die über
50 Einzelprojekte sollen 250 Millionen
Tonnen Kohlenstoff binden und 10
Millionen grüne Arbeitsplätze schaffen
meine hofft sich davon also viele
nachhaltige gesellschaftliche und
wirtschaftliche Verbesserungen für die
Menschen der Region wir haben aber immer
noch massive Probleme wegen der
politisch instabilen Lage und den
bestehenden Konflikten in manchen
Ländern in Burkina Faso ist es zur Zeit
besonders schlimm es gab dort dieses
Jahr schon zwei militär-kurs und im
Norden des Landes sind islamistische
Terrorgruppen aktiv die selben Gruppen
operieren auch in den angrenzenden Sahel
Ländern Mali und Niger allein die BOKU
haram ist in vier der an der erweiterten
great greenwall beteiligten Länder aktiv
aus dem betroffenen Gebieten halten sich
die Mitarbeiter der great greenwall
verständlicherweise fern und natürlich
will auch niemand Geld dorthin schicken
aber Geld ist noch mal ein ganz anderes
Thema auf dass wir hier leider aus
Zeitgründen nicht näher eingehen können
aber wenn ihr mehr dazu lesen wollt dann
schaut mal unter dieser Quelle hier nach
nur so viel auch Korruption spielt
leider eine Rolle all das und die
Pandemie macht die ohnehin schon
schwierige Organisation und Umsetzung
eines solchen mega Projekts noch
herausfordernder umso beeindruckender
ist dass das Projekt trotzdem ganz
langsam an Fahrt aufgenommen hat bis
2020 wurden 200.000 Quadratkilometer
Fläche erneuert und 10 Millionen
Menschen mit aufklärungsprojekten über
nachhaltiges Land und Wassermanagement
erreicht das schaffte 350.000 neue
Arbeitsplätze wodurch die Wirtschaft
wachsen konnte aber das ist ja wie
gesagt nur ein Bruchteil des eigentlich
angehalten Ziel ist das Projekt müsste
viermal so schnell durchgezogen werden
wie bisher um die Ziele für 2030
einzuhalten und dafür braucht man
natürlich auch Geld bis zu 37 Milliarden
US-Dollar fehlten noch 2020
die internationale Gemeinschaft hat
inzwischen über 19 Milliarden davon
versprochen es klingt super aber
Versprechungen sind leider nicht
verpflichtend ironischer Weise könnte
der Klimawandel dem Sahel sogar ein
bisschen helfen laut einer aktuellen
Modellrechnung könnte es in der
Sahelzone bis 2014 und bis zu 50% mehr
regnen eine Nebenwirkung davon dass ich
auch der Monsunregen durch den
Klimawandel verstärkt global gesehen ist
das aber natürlich keine gute Nachricht
wir haben ja gesehen was der
ungewöhnlich starke Monsun dieses Jahr
im Pakistan angerichtet hat so extrem
wie im Pakistan werden die Regenfälle im
Sahel zum Glück nicht aber natürlich
werden auch dort die Temperatur extreme
größer und häufiger
die Sahelzone ist eine Warnung vor dem
was auch viele Menschen in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten durch die Klimakatastrophe
und die biodiversitätskrise zukommt der
Meeresspiegel und die Temperaturen
steigen die Wetterextreme werden stärker
und große Landflächen veröden viele
dicht besiedelte Gebiete werden deshalb
ihre Bevölkerung nicht mehr ernähren
können die Folgen werden Hunger
Verarmung und dann Migration und
Konflikte sein
die great greenwall ist ein
ambitionierter vielleicht auch
verzweifelter versucht das sahelgebiet
für die Menschen zu erhalten die erste
Idee war ein bisschen naiv aber man hat
daraus gelernt wie man es vielleicht
besser machen kann und dabei vor allem
auch die Menschen mit an Bord geholt die
Finanzierung der greatin Wall wurde
dieses Jahr weiter verbessert ob die
angepassten Strategien erfolgreich sein
werden das werden die nächsten Jahre
erst zeigen wir können es aber nur
hoffen denn das wäre extrem wichtig für
die Region und eigentlich die ganze Welt
wir halten euch hier auf dem Kanal
natürlich auf dem Laufenden wie immer
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig